John Calipari the Kentucky head coach is
here with us we'll talk to him coming up
he took a picture with Lamar Jackson the
state of Kentucky has blown up as you
you and Lamar take a picture here are
you gonna get grief from Kentucky
Wildcat fans cuz you took a probably but
I'll tell you what what a great kid yeah
and I had a question for him
can you leave you and he said no I got
to stay another year I said wow oh he
might have thought you were asking if he
could leave and go to Kentucky well he
probably is a heck of a basketball
player when you see him athletically but
I was more impressed to you know that he
is a humble bright you know this kid
he's a real deal when you recruit and
you look at the athletic how important
is that lettuce ISM if I if I we were
ranking what you're gonna look for and
you have to have this in this wears
athletic there's certain things you have
to have to get on the board yes and then
there's overriding factors it doesn't
matter if you're on the board that you
can't we're not doing this but if you
don't have at that certain level of
athleticism that if you can't guard your
position you can't guard your position I
really don't care how you play your
position and then physically size-wise
normally I like position less basketball
you were talking about Dirk and prison
gas and I love guys that can their
inside outside and they just play
basketball Anthony Davis is the Karl
towns my best players I'd like to have a
team full of six nine guys everybody six
nine one of them handles it one of them
shoots it everybody plays basketball but
you know these guys we nowadays you got
to have a certain size but I took Tyler
Ulis yes I love Tyler you five eight
five nine absolute killer coached our
team a year ago you know what's great
about it I still got paid it's amazing I
think there are a couple of games I
probably could have coached and Kentucky
would have won know yeah although you
don't have socks on oh it's raining
snowing in New York you don't have socks
on
what that I have socks on why do you
keep asking me why don't you have socks
on because when you did the Heisman I
saw skin that's oh my gosh what is that
it's inside out yeah the wrong way I got
up early can I leave my Golden State
Warriors socks on I'm be head of inside
out
did you wear them yesterday so turn them
the other way pull intro here John
Calipari Kentucky basketball coach he's
got a new book success is the only
option the art of coaching extreme
talent now available online wherever
books are sold
also new weekly podcast as well wait you
see your radio host no no but let me let
the the podcast I was approached and
they were saying podcast podcast first
of all I don't know what a podcast is
but when I when I was approached by
Twitter and Facebook back in the day I'm
always looking for what's next and how
can we be so I said our coaches doing
these podcasts they said no no okay
let's think about it what are you doing
a puck station with friends Wow
so some of the people I've met and get
them and we can just talk right 30
minutes a week from my house I had to
ask my wife do you mind if I do this
thirty minutes because it's when I come
home and I'm relaxing I got thirty
minutes a week she said now go ahead and
do it
so I'm gonna interview her I want to
interview like Papa John who just went
to five thousand stores started in one
store you know I want to I'm hoping to
get Fred Smith on to talk about the term
paper he wrote about FedEx his vision
that I believe got a C and let's talk
about this stuff so what would be the
first question you'd ask your wife
we have blue apron as part of this so
I'm gonna say would you cook for dinner
what is it how long did it take you
somebody said blue apron is great
because you can do it with your wife yes
No
not doing it with my wife just let me
know what I'm eating I'm not gonna be
chopping onion sorry not happening but
I'm gonna have her step on and say would
you would you make from blue apron today
do you do blue apron yes I have done it
you look good by the way your didn't is
it helping you stay in shape uh right
I'm doing spin you doing spin yeah with
socks no socks yeah socks on no
underwear yeah do you exercise yes
elliptical I can't do I had both hips
replaced so I can't do the jog anymore
that I used to doing a treadmill I do a
lip too cool I do I'm gonna get back to
this week cuz we're we're finals and no
school and all that I'm the lifting a
little bit do you lift no a little bit
yeah I could tell but yeah you know yeah
I'm genuine mean I'm sort of like a
thoroughbred I'm a little more Jackson
of sportscasters is what I am built that
same way but but have you did you ever
get to the point though did your wife
ever get to the point was there was
there friction because of what you do
you're moving and yeah like did I ever
get to the point where sure sure I mean
she
there were times that like you know she
would never get involved in anything I
was doing because she said I didn't buy
into that I'm not going to that function
I'm not gonna hear you speak I don't
need to be there that's you I have the
kids
she was always concerned with the kids
she was always miss no no if can you
know the kids are gone she's become miss
yes she goes on road trips she so I'm
going out to dinner with the guys and
she said where you going I said I'm
going to deserves to get of death what
I'm going with 12 guys and you're gonna
say yes if I ask you something so she's
you know but early on it's tough it's a
you know it's all-consuming and and if
you have children your wife is gonna say
if it's you or my children they need me
more than you do it this time but also
you can take the heat you know that the
heat comes with the job but it's your
kids if they go to school or online or
your wife that's something you can't
control
I have Erin and Meghan that if you talk
about two
they will fight why I've seen your
daughter with some of her tweet yeah oh
yeah she's she's gonna come out you
should have her on the show cause she'd
be funnier than Mitch she's unbelievable
but she would fight my wife isn't bad
she doesn't get on the internet as much
she's starting to I'm like why are you
doing that but I'm coaching my son and
our fans have been great to him but on
the internet social media who takes some
shots and I go those are the haters of
me they don't know who you are you know
why would you even look at that stuff so
it life has changed with social media to
what it was 20 years ago 15 years ago
we're all more transparent which I kind
of like that you can't be defined by
someone else they they kind of you're
out there now did your son ask for
advice on where he should play
basketball he didn't ask for advice on
picking a prep school and he came to me
and said I think I want to do this and I
just said you know you're not gonna play
much here he's a walk-on you know but I
do sleep with his mother so he does get
it but I he said you know I want to be
challenged I want to see how good I can
get and I may want to get into coaching
so that's why I want to do it I said
okay let's go I remember was it who is
it
Memphis head coach Pastner he said to
Josh Josh he was with Josh Pastner you
know they won a big game Georgia Tech it
Virginia Virginia Commonwealth you watch
all basketball right I watched a lot
I've been watching a high school
basketball as sad as that's gonna sound
you have no life no but I remember Josh
was with lute Olson at Arizona I think
and he wanted to become a head coach and
you could see where he was helping coach
while he was there as a player so I mean
it's a smart move on your son's part but
I man I'd be weird a little bit coaching
your son yeah oh I love it I love it and
I'm I get on him like if he's not
smiling he's grumpy oh you better be
smiling in front of the team I want him
to be coached I want him to his shooting
going a little south and he and I got in
the gym and I worked on it look I coach
everyone else's child how about I get a
chance to be with my own child and you
know you talk I had a son yeah if I had
a son I'd want him to be how Brandis the
only problem is you've got a tattoo a
tattoo ice across this Chad he's got it
he's got a breastplate I mean okay
didn't ask us didn't that now who did I
hear from right away his mom why did you
let him do it like I let him do it you
tell him to take that off I don't think
you can take it off honey I don't think
tattoos come off I do you mean he's got
to keep yes so now he's got to wear a
shirt overnight and I would tell all the
young people out there if you get a
tattoo just hide it until you make it
and then tattoo your eyes shut it
doesn't matter at that point until you
make it you got to be able to cover
whenever tattoo you have if you walk
into sell Xerox and you got this tattoo
on your face
I don't maybe but I don't think they're
gonna buy your machine I just don't
think so
so again then he had another one and I
called him and I said ho-ho another
tattoo you're not on this team do you do
what we like speaking the same language
now so because I was here two from his
mother she's killing me God why are you
yelling at me yell at him what that's a
big commitment to the breastplate tattoo
that's a big yeah yeah it is any look
he's do you know would you get a tattoo
I don't like needles so I can't I'd
probably faint and then I wouldn't know
what they put on my body because I'm
usually didn't Pitino get one I have no
idea yeah I thought he did I thought he
did when they won the national title how
about if you win the national title no
I'm gonna say it again if they show me a
needle I'm out okay pick what you want
and all of a sudden I wake up I get
I got sideburns uh but I will continue
with John Calipari once again the book
is in bookstores and available online
successes we will talk about that that
is when we come back you brought up the
tattoo you brought up the podcast
success is the only option the art of
coaching extreme talent so John Calipari
will continue we'll take a break 17
after the hour I will get to your phone
calls best and worst of the weekend I'm
watching last night yesterday you're
beating Hofstra and it you weren't
beating Hofstra by many and I thought oh
I don't think coach is coming in
tomorrow then you end up blowing him out
but you got North Carolina coming up on
Saturday are you thinking when you're
only up by two that you're maybe not
going to do this interview - no there's
no question yeah we were up three and
I'm like I'm looking for my guy Eric cuz
I'm thinking call him right now and
cancel it but we got it going I thought
booth good did you want to lose so you
didn't have to come in no I'd never want
to lose no okay no but that was Hofstra
played well by the way I mean Joe
mahalik got those guys playing they they
compete they got a quick backcourt like
these guards are really quick and fast
the UCLA lost how surprised were you not
I mean here's the great thing about our
profession Steve Alford is doing a great
job with that team and they're playing
the way they have to play to have
success you were asking me about ball
whether you also got these other
perimeter shooters who they play Alonzo
ball is the star freshman right but leaf
is the one who told us yeah and I didn't
expect him to be that good but when I
watched the game I'm like he is really
good and you know it here's our
profession a year ago they're running
planes around UCLA that Steve what yeah
he gives back a million dollars - oh
they don't mess with his assistants
think about it and they may be the best
team in the country and may win a
national title a year later and that's
why I say this profession is crazy
everybody wants it now this year what
are we doing how do we do this is a
process and all of us now are coaching
young guys which makes it even more of a
process in November in these
member they should be different as we
get to January in February in March
because we're so young would you've got
would you get into this profession now
if you're 20 to 23
it's totally it's a change profession
and I will tell you that you know where
this used to be about the profession
it's about these kids now where before
the coaches coach you know running the
drills and he's tough and this thing has
now become not only on the basketball
court but we're having these kids for a
short period of time how do you prepare
them for what's ahead a man's world in
this short period of time how do you
teach them to be servant leaders what it
really means to be a servant leader how
do you teach them to get involved in
society to help to create joy how do you
teach them to be happy every day all
those things in there in the book by the
way well did you read the book no I
didn't even get the book so why don't me
off you put out a new book every six
months he's talking I was only having
Eon to talk about the loss to UCLA I
want to talk about your son's tattoos
look look here's what I would say to you
the best thing for me is when I see the
growth look at the the community assist
award in the NBA John Wall won it that's
a big time award you know who the
runner-up was Anthony Davis yes and you
know who was a top ten finisher DeMarcus
Cousins you see DeMarcus flew the family
from Sacramento into New York to be at
the game to do a shop our kids get that
this is more than just playing
basketball and it isn't just so
dedicated to the profession you got to
be dedicated to these kids that's the
biggest change I've seen in the last 20
years but I noticed even with my own
kids kids now want to be told hey you
did a great job participatory trophies
and as a coach
the change in players is it a softer
generation where you need to encourage
you can't yell well here's where we are
with this current team it's not
it's coaching like they think come on
now I mean I'm gonna tell you I'm talk
about ice cream at times but how do you
challenge these kids to be what they can
be to believe in themselves more than
they do right now yet have them be
confident well you remember us as
eighteen and nineteen year old that's a
hard that's the challenge of this
especially when every one of them in our
case coaching extreme talent NBA oh
they're on that pet McDonald's
all-americans thirty points a game the
only guy in their team the center of
attention now seven eight of them come
together and they want to be together by
the way extreme talent wants to be with
other extreme talent how do you get them
to share how do you get them to feel
good and fulfilled doing less scoring
less less minutes maybe not starting
Devin Booker
didn't start Anthony Davis fourth most
shots
do you work Moshe you were right and you
you brought it up a couple times about
how great Devin Booker was going to be
and you you even brought that up at the
draft that people don't realize how
great a shooter this kid is and and Trey
Lyles who's doing well and I would say
this and I've been wrong before I think
it was 78 there was a right I took one
left I mean it was just one of those
things but that's the new challenge for
us see look you Joe asked me before the
game how do you keep these guys happy
how do you get all and you're coaching
them and making them play and the
biggest thing is you can't appeal to
their ego shots minutes I'm gonna make
you the fit you're you're appealing to
their aspirations do you want to be the
best version of yourself then you've got
to practice against other good players
every day if you walk in a gym as a
player and you're by far the most
talented guy in the gym you're in the
wrong gym that's not the gym you want to
be in you want to walk in a gym and say
holy cow look at all these guys and then
every day that's how you get better or
you get broken it's one of the two you
got to say
can do this and then the last piece of
this they got to know they're
responsible for themselves
I don't have a magic wand the magic wand
for us is we're all together we're all
here to get better we're all going to
learn about servant leadership and
sharing we're gonna learn to be a great
teammate all of us and then you're
responsible for you you have to perform
the book paulie's got it over there it's
a success is the only option the art of
why did you say you didn't get a book
Paulie got it he just got it we just got
it all it just came this morning yeah oh
yeah yeah
did you get that it was sent to my house
about a week and a half ago oh okay
so Paulie was gonna read it and tell you
so you wouldn't have to read so you put
your socks on backwards yeah we're back
okay is there Cliff Notes version of
that because that would help me a little
bit better coach right you use cliff
notes in college right no no no no no I
like I love reading so I've read all the
time it's a good book by the way you
should look at it I don't Paulie don't
tell me how that book ends I don't want
to know how that ends you're sick
good luck against North Carolina tough
game about rebounding how about rebound
I don't know try that I don't know yeah
we're gonna do mean you can write this
book maybe spend less time right in the
book and you're right you're right exact
nobody box out anymore I know they don't
think they look at the ball because
because I'm your man no no you sweat on
sweat like you don't want to get sweat
on you so if you bother you get sweat
they're like just run the other way men
I'm not touching you so we're we're soon
as it goes up you find your man right
yeah you've put a body on them
absolutely tell the kid do you want me
to help you on I will a teacher son out
of shoot want me to you couldn't teach
my son how to shoot my son can shoot so
one thing he can do and you ask are you
sure that's how are you sure he's your
son if he can really shoot not bad not a
bad question not a bad question look I
was faster and quicker than him he's
stronger if I said your sous-chefs key
in a and Pacino in a shoot-off right now
15 foot jumpers I'm winning that well
I have to shoot for a week to give
myself that because I'm having been
shooting but yeah really oh yeah yeah
yeah
Coach K was a great high school player
played an army and Pitino he was ladies
you mess yeah he was up there with dr. J
yeah and I and did I play I don't know I
don't know either did you play date no
and then thanks for Kentucky did you
make a basket yeah okay that's good
thing yeah
anything else you want this guy you
don't want the scouting report by the
way it's a new book it's by John
Calipari it's uh you write more books
than JK Rowling dude I'm done my I told
my wife if I even think about another no
more boys smash me in the face I told
her the next time you write a book you
got to get a tattoo um that's a good one
because there would be no more books
success is the only option the art of
coaching extreme talent also the podcast
weekly podcast by a coach Cal good luck
against Carolina always great to see you
great scene by the way coach brought to
you by the coaches corner Continental
Tire coaches corner brought to you by
the great folks at Continental Tire
you'll see their signage at college
basketball arenas around the country
Continentals premium products available
at leading independent tire dealers car
dealers mass retail companies across
North America for more information visit
Continental Tire Calm Continental Tire
for what you do
back after this the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]